well I hoped never to see you again
what's that dog we're back ladies nobody
gave a [ __ ] about the Jump Street reboot
but you got lucky so now this department
has invested a lot of money to make sure
Jump Street keeps going the only problem
is the Koreans bought the church back so
we're moving you across the road to 22
Jump Street you two sons of [ __ ] are
going to cockroach
[ __ ] yeah
one bathrooms [ __ ] I'm not gonna take a
[ __ ] the entire time we're here we'll go
around classes and activities past
around about the drug find out who the
dealer is you look older is everyone in
college look like babies Shh
some of us are trying to study so you
take it down to a level of shut up
is this a level you're looking for sure
you look really old to oldest [ __ ] to be
here partners for life
it's just drinking games and bonding why
is that so painful for you no you cannot
hug me right now drunk stagger swag
don't rap we Jump Street and we about to
jump in your ass mm-hmm right in the
crack we need an expert to consult
oh listen mr. Walters I should apologize
for shooting my penis off don't sweat it
they gave me a vagina hey guess what I'm
Eric's [ __ ] I know you're nice yeah you
won't ass ass oh my god
there